hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast structure and function of
epigenetic regulators and human disease
presented by dr. sagall Kadosh an
assistant professor of pediatric
oncology at the Dana Farber Cancer
Institute and Harvard Medical School and
an institute member of the Broad
Institute of MIT and Harvard and joining
her dr. Chris Frey director of product
development at cell signal technology
I'm Suzy Valdez of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's events we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by self signaling technology
silo signaling technology is a private
family-owned company founded by
scientists and dedicated to provide the
world's highest quality innovative
research and diagnostic products to
accelerate biological understanding and
enable personalized medicine before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located at the
lower left of your presentation window
and type your questions into the box
that appear on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of this presentation also please
notice that you're viewing this
presentation in this slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
during the presentation you'll have the
opportunity to answer some poll
questions for our presenters we
encourage you to preciate and appreciate
your participation and we encourage you
to do so if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use that Q&A
button to let us know you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the button on
the left corner and follow the process
for obtaining your credit
without further ado I'd like to
introduce our two presenters first dr.
sagall kadosh dr. kadosh is an assistant
professor of pediatric oncology at the
Dana Farber Cancer Institute and Harvard
Medical School an institute member of
the Broad Institute of MIT and Harvard
doctor kadosh studies chromatin
regulation with strong focus on the
structure and function of the mammalian
switch snip or bas family of chromatin
remodelling complexes and human cancer
her work has been centered in
mechanistically interrogating rare
molecular lis well-defined cancers to
understand the role these complexes play
in promoting a wide range of more common
cancer types joining her our second
presenter is dr. Chris Frey dr. Frey
earned his PhD in oncology from the
University of wisconsin-madison
where he examined the mechanisms of e to
s mediated gene regulation during g1 and
s phases of the McMillion mammalian cell
cycle dr. fiving carried out his
postdoctoral studies at the University
of Massachusetts Medical Center where he
studied mechanisms governing the gene
regulation silencing and chromatin
dynamics during the cell cycle in the
yeast Saccharomyces cerevisiae chris is
a currently director of the product
development at cell signaling technology
where he leads two teams one that
focuses on the development of antibodies
again protein and non protein targets
involving epigenetics and the other
focusing on the development of products
for chromatin IP for complete
biographies on these two speakers please
visit our website or click on their
picture in the left hand corner of your
presentation window I will now turn the
presentation over to our speakers
starting with dr. kadosh welcome Thank
You Sussie for the nice introduction and
good afternoon from Boston everyone and
a special thanks to cell signaling
technologies and lab roots for
sponsoring this event and for the
opportunity to participate so as some of
you may know our laboratory is
interested in
standing the structure and function of
large atp-dependent chromatin
remodelling complexes most notably the
mammalian switch sniff or bass family of
chromatin remodeling complexes in our
group places particular emphasis on
understanding how perturbation to the
individual subunits or components of
these complexes can play driving or
contributing roles in human disease so
this is a large this is the large beast
of a couple of three studies shown here
drawn artistically to scale with its
local nucleosomal
environment these complexes utilize the
energy of ATP hydrolysis to essentially
mobilize note nucleus films thereby
allowing for timely and appropriate gene
expression
now before we get started at several key
rules become particularly important in
terms of how we think about these
complexes so the individual components
are highly stable with one another that
they can resist association in over
two-and-a-half malaria so they're highly
stable interlocking interactions the
subunits are entirely dedicated to the
complex meaning they have no monomeric
forms they don't participate in other
complexes so they're entirely dedicated
to this family of chromatin remodelers
using antibodies to one subunit or
another will deplete the entire complex
and actually been able to use those
methods to be able to uncover aspects of
how these complexes are assembled in
more recent studies that we'll talk
about today and finally there's no
exchange of subunits in vitro so if one
purify the complex and tries to bombard
it with very high concentrations in a
test-tube
the additional subunit will not exchange
in demography complexes now particularly
as we start to think about this family
of chromatin remodeling complexes
historically they were quite challenging
to study in that top tagging or any kind
of over expression can severely alter
the binding interactions and
strychometric relationships within the
complex and so until we have the use of
nice high affinity antibodies including
those by cell signaling technology to
the surfaces of these complexes they
were quite challenging to purify and
study endogenously
there are 29 genes in total that encode
the various blood subunits you can see
from this schematic there aren't 29
subunits shown there and that is because
they are assembled in a combinatorial
fashion with several families having one
or more peril
but never both able to assemble into
that position a few examples of those
are the two ATP ASE's burg one and berm
also known as smart day for smart day
two those are the two mutually exclusive
ATP ASE's and another family with para
legis subunits fitting a position in the
complex or arid 1a and arid 1b which
actually are the most frequently mutated
subunits in human cancer these complexes
have evolved from East and as you can
see from the schematic over the course
of evolution subunits have been gains
lost and shuffle this is likely due to
the advent of things like
multicellularity linking histones
polycomb a de jure oppression and in
general a larger genome size so these
reflect the current mammalian public's
view on the right hand side of the slide
with all the subunits identified to date
now we're particularly interested in
this complex owing to a surge of recent
studies which have repeatedly revealed
frequent mutations to the genes encoding
the various subunits within the
mammalian switchin if complex and as
shown in this very simplified schematic
we can estimate if we add all these exon
mutations up so that these mutations are
frequent in over 20% of human cancers
this was actually derived from a 2013
article that we published and this
number continues to rise
intriguingly the couple of subunit
mutations appear as a broad pattern
across a range of tumor types much like
that of p53 and from observing all these
mutations across these tumor types
several key themes emerge as I mentioned
several subunits are mutating very
specific malignancies and nowhere else
so there are very clear examples of that
and we'll speak about that in this
presentation
now other subunits are mutated across a
much wider range of cancer suggesting
some defining commonalities between them
intriguingly in both the most frequent
mutations most regular mutated subunits
are actually not those that are required
for in vitro chromatin remodeling and
this is a major problem for the field
because the textbook definition you know
employs purified complexes put together
recombinant ly and placed on nucleosomal
templates artificial chromatin eyes
templates however as we learn from the
invivo mutational pattern
here this is likely an insufficient set
of assays to assess function and so our
lab has had a major interest and
understanding new assays which might be
able to robustly
and accurately read on the function of
these complex complexes the mutations
also can be heterozygous and of course
this implicates gene dosage effects so
this was where we were you know as the
first set of 50 or so exon sequencing
studies emerged onto the landscape
behind the field and at the same time a
set of several studies emerge this is in
2012 in a collection of papers
discussing intellectual disability
syndromes particularly coughing serous
syndrome Nicolay disparate source
syndrome and as you can note in all
three of these papers all through
published in Nature Genetics the word
cause was using the title and all of
these papers implicated the genes
encoding subunits within the mammalian
fiction of complex as key players in
these rare but well characterized
intellectual disabilities syndromes so
this was really the first time we could
detect that mutations that are found
here can be heterozygous and to support
the idea that heterozygous mutations can
have driver effects and have low
sufficiency gene dosage alterations
within the complex a more modern view of
this if we look at more modern TCGA data
this number continues to rise now over
23 almost 24 percent and as you can see
in comparing the million switching it
for bass complices to the other
chromatin remodeling complexes really
stands head and shoulders in this play
and outside contribution moreover on the
right hand side of the slide if we look
at the somatic mutation frequencies in
cases in which which have a vast complex
mutation you can see that the overall
mutation frequency appears to be lower
than those cancers that bear mutations
in these other complexes suggesting
again that these could be playing a
driver or at least strongly contributing
roles to those cancers but of course
there's more than just the exons within
the genome and so if we extend some of
these analyses to examine both copy
number variations and adding in by
allelic deletion the loss of
heterozygosity this never continues to
rise and now if you add that estimation
it's about 30 percent of all human
cancers of course if we continue to add
additional categories of ways by which
this couple can be perturbed including
promote
enhancer mutations methylation other
means of epigenetic silencing of key
promoters this list can go on and on and
we estimate that this is still a vast
underestimation of the total percent of
human cancers which have some
perturbation to this vast complex so all
these exciting genomic results have
really catalyzed a wave of interest from
a variety of angles both within our lab
and in the field as a whole with
understanding a public specific complex
composition and architecture which is
one of the topics I'll talk about today
how loss of one pair log subunit can
actually create a an actionable
synthetic lethality with its remaining
pair log trying to understand the
function of specific domains within the
complex how other factors can tether to
the surfaces of these regulators to
drive their targeting on the genome etc
and this is another topic we'll discuss
today in the webinar so how complex are
these complexes really if we now look at
all the positions within the complex
that have a mutually exclusive
virologist subunit able to incorporate
we get about eight positions within the
complex at which a physician exists such
as this and buy and choose our
combinatorics we arrive at over a
thousand possibilities as to how these
complexes can be put together that's
quite a lot of possibilities in terms of
thinking about how one might perform
universe invitation or chip seek assays
etc fortunately tissue specificity can
help us out a little bit with that
so if we now take a much more restricted
cell type like a fiberglass by gene
expression we only have about five
positions within the complex at which
one of these mutually exclusive subunits
can incorporate and so now again playing
the same game with entries or
combinatoric we arrive at or two orders
of magnitude or so lower number of
possible compliment of L so suffice to
say that the combinatorial assembly the
quite complex combinatorial assembly of
these complexes gives rise to a great
deal of biologic specificity and
proteomic studies by our group and
others both in a wide range of wild-type
cell types as well as now cancer and
other disease specific cell types can
continue to uncover these very specific
forms
of VAS compost compositions so why does
this combinatorial assembly matter and
how does that dictate the biologic
specificity of course within the complex
there exist DNA binding domains on
certain subunits histone recognition
motifs such as pH D fingers etc and also
the tissues that there are tissue
specific transcription factor binding
sites across the surfaces of these
complexes that have not yet been defined
but all three of these can drastically
contribute to the targeting of these
complexes and as a whole actually much
like the field for many other permits
and regulators as well it's it remains
to be understood exactly how these
complexes get to where they need to go
on the genome so you know where we see
the field we have an unprecedented
understanding of the genetic landscape
of human cancer there are hundreds of
thousands now full at some cases is this
slide can't stay up to date enough that
are not been published vast complexes
are mutating over 20% of all these human
cancers making it the most frequently
mutated chromatin regulator and on the
other side of things we have results
from high-throughput assays omics
everything shrna and CRISPR screens for
synthetic lethal relationship
large-scale small molecule screens gene
expression studies and a whole genome
level and genome-wide histone mark that
have been deposited globally including
encode roadmap etc but what's really
missing is the bridge between these two
and so our lab focuses on the
biochemistry of these complexes
understanding their composition and
stoichiometry their structure and their
topology and understanding where they
where they get to where they need to go
on the genome by their histone mark and
sequence specific targeting mechanisms
we believe that these this missing link
really is a significant barrier to the
identification of targeted therapeutics
and so our lab aims to focus in that
nexus right there so to try to place
this missing link we recognize that
there may be opportunities in unique but
well well-defined rare cancer types and
so we ask the question can we harness
the power of alpha genetic drivers
irrefutable oncogenic drivers to
understand fundamental questions in vast
complex biology and similarly could we
take what we have learned about the
composition of these complexes across a
wide range of cell types to inform the
mechanism
in this case a nerve cancer called
synovial sarcoma so our goal would be if
we can take these rare cancers that are
well-defined genetically translate them
into a mechanistic understanding as to
how they drive forward an oncogenic gene
expression program then build screens
for some molecules targeting these
regulators the goal would be that we
could then do this for the wide range of
human patients that have a large number
of public mutations so I'll talk about a
few of these rare cancers and our
progress in that realm today
we originally got into this having
identified this protein called ss-18 as
a stable and dedicated member of bath
complexes and we've cared to study this
in particular in that a hundred percent
of patients that have a rare but highly
aggressive form of sarcoma called
synovial sarcoma Bera this very specific
chromosomal translocation whereby ss-18
on chromosome 18 fuses in frame with SS
x genes on chromosome X and by virtue of
this chromosomal translocation a fusion
protein is created and this is using
exactly 78 amino acids of the SS x tail
onto the SS 18 subunit in every single
case and so this provides strong support
of course for an initiating role and so
our lab was to try to study these I will
go through much of this work as it is
published but intriguing ly what we were
able to identify that the product of
this translocation the SS taking at the
sex feed and protein incorporates and
usurps into bath complexes there by
displacing the progress of the wild-type
allele while Texas is a teen looking at
the right hand side of this line and
displacing and degrading the bath 47 or
sort via one subunit as a complex this
led to a retargeting of bath complexes
on the genome and for example we're
targeting to a gene called Sox 2 to
activate that gene and this gene was
critical for the proliferative maintance
of these cells
excitingly we discovered that this
process was reversible if we simply
change the stoichiometric balance
between wild-type ss-18 and ss-18 fsx we
could actually shuffle between the
oncogenic form of these complexes and
they're well typed counterparts so if we
rescued these complexes now to take them
back to those form on the left hand side
of this line we saw that these
retargeted bath complexes
salted INRI silencing of the sox2 gene
by h3k27 trimethylation place by
polycomb complexes and a significant
phenotype of synovial sarcoma cells and
culture so this was a particularly
exciting cancer example whereby bass
complexes are essentially hijacked by
this oxygen diffusion and it's brought
about several new questions in the sense
that it is really the first
gain-of-function mechanism identified
across the literature for bass complexes
as I showed you on the other slide the
large majority of these are loss of
function gene deletion type mutations
but this is a gain of function so this
suggests that fusion of new proteins or
domains all of these complexes can
profoundly alter the targeting their
targeting on the genome and this
targeting will recruit all the
activating features of these complexes
to new sites so we were really curious
if this mechanism of action could extend
do any other cancers and if so what
types and what new opportunities would
this bring so in work that was just
published two weeks ago and so we
identified the ews protein which is a
set member and the member of fuse top-15
and ews these are RNA binding proteins
can actually tether to the surfaces of
these complexes and enjoying some other
characteristic chromosomal translocation
they're produces the ews fly one in
fusion protein we identify as shown on
the upper left-hand panel in a 673 and a
scan and see you in sarcoma sewing that
that bear the EWS fly wound fusion
protein that we can find that this
fusion protein binds to bath complexes
as assessed by the lower panel this IP
two birds one ATP member of the complex
you can see here that EWS and fly one
the fusion protein are now tethered to
the complexes in this set so we ask what
happens then at a genome-wide level on
chromatin to do this we assess us using
chip seek methods and we found that the
large majority of EWS fly one target
sites overlapped with bath complex sites
on the genome in a wing sarcoma cells so
you can see that this large motif that
is enriched the GGA a repetitive on
repeat enhancer motif was largely shared
with these Bassem 65 sites as shown in
the Venn diagram an example of that is
shown at the CC and e1 locus where you
can see nice co-localization
GWS fly 1,055 indeed sugar 27 a subtle
and on the right hand side you can see
the density diagrams reflecting a very
similar pattern of enrichment over the
GG a repeat enhancers so what happens
then if we perturb the levels of this
oncogenic fusion in these cancer cell
lines by knocking down fly one you can
send the left hand side successful
knockdown of the fly one as shown by me
to blot and if we now look what happens
you know why we see that upon not
suppression of the e2b fly one fusion
vast complexes are significantly
diminished over these g GAA repeat
enhancers suggesting the fly one
component individual infusion protein is
able to recruit vas complexes to these
sites now reciprocal II what happens if
we put in and introduce EWS y1 into
naive and the thinking will stem cells
on the right hand side of the slide we
can see that if we did this we get a
major enrichment of Bascom 55 sites over
the GG a repeat enhancers as shown in
the summary graph there and importantly
we demonstrated that this is dependent
on the function of the vas complex in
that if we overexpress EWS y1 and look
at the RNA seek so these are the genes
that are now activated in the zinc for
whole stem cells EWS fly one of the
fusion is able to activate all of those
target genes however if we pair uws fly
one over expression with knockdown of
the bird when ATPase of the vast complex
you can see a dramatic attenuation in
this ability importantly we ended up
attributing this oncogenic fusion uncle
orthodontic effect of the EWS level
infusion to the prion like activity
homework to the end terminus of the EWS
our one protein so if we now look at
this GWS our one protein they have two
major domains containing from like
features particularly tyrosine so one
now mutates those key tyrosines that
contribute to the prion like activity of
the EWS our one projet we can see a
dramatic attenuation in the ability to
undergo a phase transition as assessed
in the in the Western blot shown on the
lower left-hand panel using on
generated a sock sizzle which provides a
nice readout for phase transition and
importantly if we now look in cell by
introducing either full-length EWS y1 or
now the mutant bearing all the mutant
tyrosine residues we can see a dramatic
change in the ability of this fly one to
to recruit bass complexes and to enable
activation is assessed by a trick 8:27 a
subtle over the site so the model for
this cancer is that in wild-type the
wild XY one is unable to activate these
enhancers the EWS y one fusion homework
two these tumors requiring the trial
unlike domain activates these GGA repeat
enhancers if one makes in mutations to
the prior like domain enhancer is unable
to be activated and finally if we just
fuse the problem like features to the
fly one x factor you can see a dramatic
activation of these enhancers so finally
as we highlighted in the earlier part of
the slides the large majority of these
mutations that have been covered in
human cancer are a loss of function in
the sense of Jeannot Jeannot genetic
loss of function the gene is lost for
example in malignant raspberry tumour
mrt the bat 47 subunit or sparky one
subunit is biologically inactivated we
were here to explore this and so taking
a set of cell lines are deficient in the
47 subunits we rescued by 47 to examine
the genome-wide effects and we can
appreciate from this slide and looking
at vast complex communication by chip we
can see a dramatic increase in the
global widespread targeting of this
complex in every single cell line so
upon rescue about 47 we see a major
increase in the chromatin occupancy
widespread throughout the genome and
this is reflected further here with the
density diagram showing at the by 47
subunit plays a very critical role in
enabling the bascopolous to bind
chromatin and so this may begin to shed
light on the larger number of human
cancers that have bath complex
perturbations as well as the various
others that have different mechanisms
and how we might be able to consider
those so in summary what I've told you
is that these backups the most
frequently mutated chrome with the
regulators in human cancer the
perturbations can result in either
loss or gain of function phenotype
synovial sarcoma would the ss-18 of the
sex fusion was the first
gain-of-function bass-driven cancer that
we identified but now we know these
mechanisms can expand to Ewing sarcoma
and likely others and finally invest 47
loss-of-function cancers such as
malignant rhabdo tumor rescue about 47
can restore widespread chromatin
occupancy and so with that I'll thank
the members of my lab our collaborators
on this work and my sources of support
and you for your attention thank you and
now we'll turn it over to Chris Frey
from cell signaling technologies for the
next talk thank you so golfers a great
talk thank you to lab roots for
supporting our webinar and good morning
good afternoon and good evening to our
viewers out there I just need to flip
over to my slides my name is Christopher
Frye I'm a director of epigenetics
product development at cell signaling
technology and today I want to talk
about the chip assay and really talk
about things to consider when you're
planning a successful chip assay so I'll
spend just a couple minutes briefly
giving an introduction to chip both chip
and chip seek and then I want to talk
about really three keys to a successful
chip experiment the first one being an
optimized protocol high quality reagents
next we'll talk about cross-linking and
chromatin fragmentation and then finally
we'll talk about the chip the validated
antibodies so what is chip chip is a
powerful technique that's used to
identify and analyze protein DNA
interactions within the genome in vivo
you can use it to look at binding of
histones and histone modifications
transcription factors and cofactor
proteins replication factors and DNA
repair proteins you can use this method
to look at single gene analysis using
chip qPCR here is where you would look
at a handful of interesting target genes
or you could use it and look at whole
genome mapping of the the protein or
histone modification now in the chip
assay cells or tissues are first fixed
with formaldehyde and this cross links
histones and non-histone proteins to the
DNA the cells are tissue are then lice
and nuclei are prepared
kommen turn is fragmented either by
sonication or enzymatic digestion into
150 to 900 base pair DNA protein
fragments once that is done the nuclei
are lysed and fragmented in chromatin is
isolated we then can add antibodies that
are specific to histones or non-histone
proteins and then we add protein g or
protein a beads to help IP and enrich
these antibody chromatin fragments from
the chromatin sample we can reverse the
cross links and purify the DNA and then
we can analyze this DNA to see what DNA
we've immuno enriched using the antibody
and this can be analyzed by one or two
of two methods chip qPCR or chip seek
with chip qpcr you can design primers
against a handful or or so of your
target genes of interest and use qPCR to
identify and quantify the enrichment of
these target genes with chip seek you
can actually generate a DNA library and
then identify and quantify and map these
binding regions back to the whole genome
now a poll question should be popping up
on your screen I wanted to get an idea
how many of our reviewers use chip how
many our reviews are doing chip qPCR or
chip seek or both so please if you will
select which one you're doing and let us
know what what type of asset you're
performing while you're doing that I'm
going to continue on with my slides so
next I wanted to spend most of my talk
really focusing on three areas that
think about when planning a successful
chip experiment the first one is use of
reliable optimized protocol next you
want to we'll talk about cross-linking
and fragmenting chromatin and finally
we'll talk about the antibodies that you
use in your experiment so so when
starting a chip protocol you want to you
really want to use a reliable optimized
protocol whether it be a homebrew
call that you find that as well
published or is being used by a chip lab
or it's a kid that you buy from a
company and at CST we provide multiple
chromatin IP kits here's two on the
slide here the simple chip plus
sonication chromatin IP kit and the
simple chip plus enzymatic chromatin IP
kit both kits use magnetic protein G
beads they work with cells and hold
tissue samples they're compatible with
chip QP CRN chip seek and they work for
histones transcription factors and
cofactors so really these kits both work
for really you know everything you don't
need a specific kit for specific protein
types these kids contain all the buffers
and reagents required to do the chip
they have a complete detailed protocol
they're actually simpler than most
competitor kits they have DNA
purification columns which are required
for downstream qPCR and NGC can alysus
and they also contain a universal
positive central histone h3 antibody and
negative control normal IgG antibody and
using these antibodies in combination
with the positive control primer sets
really helps ensure your experimental
success regardless of whether your
antibody of interest is working or not
these antibodies will tell you that your
chromatin is working for an IEE
experiment so next I want to spend some
time talking about cross-linking and
fragmenting the chromatin there are two
methods that could be used to fragment
chromatin enzymatic digestion shown here
on the left in blue and sonication shown
here on the right in orange a poll
question will pop up on your screen
asking which method you use to fragment
your chromatin and please indicate by
checking on the box either sonication or
enzymatic or both yes so what enzymatic
cells are lysed in a low detergent
buffer
we then fragment by digesting with micro
kar komak nuclease and micro coco
nucleases an enzyme that digests
double-stranded DNA in between the
nucleosomes
once the digestion is complete we
briefly sonic ate to lice the nuclei the
nuclei and the chromatin is purified by
centrifuging out the insoluble material
now mas digestion is very mild it's done
in a low detergent buffer at 37 degrees
and we actually recommend doing a
partial digest and what you get is shown
here in the gel electrophoresis on the
right the second Lane shows DNA that is
purified from a mas based chromatin
digestion as you see here you see a
ladder of DNA fragments from 150 to 700
base pairs so in orange on the right is
shown the sonication protocol here we
give me do a cell lysis in a low
detergent buffer and then we Sonic 8 the
chromatin and we used the energy of a
lead as acoustic energy to sonic 8 the
chromatin into small fragments now the
sonication can be done in a number of
different conditions some protocols use
a low detergent buffer other protocols
use a high detergent buffer and
different types of sonic caters can be
used traditionally a probe sonicator has
been used for chip but newer water baths
and ultra focus on Decatur's can be used
regardless of the sonicator used you
need to do a bit of optimization for the
sonication protocol and this is
important because there's different
classes of chip targets that are
different classes of protein targets
that behave differently in the chip
assay so there's histones which are very
stable e bound to DNA and there's a
large number of histones per DNA
fragment these proteins are thus
relatively easy to chip and they're
insensitive to harsh conditions such as
high detergent and heat that's created
in the sonication protocol DNA binding
transcription factors are less stable
stable e bound to the DNA there's few
factors fewer factors bound to the DNA
fragment and these are more difficult to
chip they're they're much more sensitive
to harsh conditions and finally
transcription cofactors like the switch
sniff complex proteins often do not
directly contact DNA they're often part
of these large
protein complexes the antibodies might
be part antibody episodes might be
partially buried and these are actually
very difficult to chip and very
sensitive to harsh denaturing conditions
so I wanted to ask another poll question
here is what classes of protein targets
are you studying with your chip assay
histones and histone modifications
transcription factors or transcription
cofactors and you can actually check
more than one box if you're working on
different target types now again with
sonication one wants to do a bit of
optimization with the protocol and one
of the important things to consider is
the number of cycles of sonication or
sonication time you're using in your
assay shown on the left here is a gel
electrophoresis of DNA fragments that
were generated by sonication and on the
bottom we're looking at increasing time
of sonication as shown here as we as you
can see as we increase the time of
sonication we see smaller and smaller
fragments of DNA and looking at this one
might think that you know eight minute
of sonication might be the best because
it gives us a good nice tight band of
chromatin fragments however if we look
at enrichment of target genes for the
TCF for transcription factor and beta
catenin a cofactor that binds to t CF 4
we see that the highest levels are
enrichment for cam k2d and known target
gene are found using chromatins that was
sonicated for only two to four minutes
we find that eight to ten minutes
actually decreases the enrichment that
we see by qPCR so more sonication is not
always better and so what you want to do
is you want to use the minimal number of
cycles that you can to get chromatin
around the size of a hundred to five
hundred or a hundred to seven hundred
base pairs in length and that should a
well if you're using the minimal number
of cycles should give you the best
enrichment now another thing to consider
is the the amount of detergent in your
sonication buffer even with optimized
cycles if you have too much detergent
you can lose signal for some
target protein types now histones are
very resistant to high detergent levels
as shown in this slide we're looking at
enrichment of tri methyl k-27 across
region of the genome here we're using
our simple chip enzymatic chromatin IP
kit our simple chip sonication chromatin
IP kit which has a low detergent buffer
and a completing competitor sonication
kit that contains a high detergent
buffer if we look at enrichment of
trimethylglycine 27 you see that all
three of these kits work equally well
giving us nice enrichment that we would
expect to see in this region of the
genome however if we look at
transcription factors and cofactors we
see a big difference here we're looking
at TCF four and two of its cofactors
that it recruits to its target genes
beta catenin and CBP if we look at the
chip seek data here we're looking at the
acs l5 target gene we see nice
enrichment of these three proteins using
simple chip and somatic kit the simple
chip sonication kit but using the high
detergent competitor sonication kit we
see absolutely no enrichment and this is
again because the high levels of a
detergent are actually denaturing the
the chromatin and disrupting the
antibody epitopes and so when you're
looking at transcription factors and
cofactors you really want to use either
enzymatic or a low detergent sonication
buffer what about tissue chip which
method works best for tissue chip well
we found that both methods the
sonication ends enzymatic work equally
well in most tissues so shown here is
chip seek data using mouse liver and
here we're using our simple chip plus
sonication chromatin IP kit on the left
and the simple chip plus enzymatic kit
on the right and the top two panels
we're looking at enrichment of tri
methyl eats releasing four and the Fox
a1 transcription factor and here we see
a very similar enrichment patterns using
both enzymatic and sonication as we
would expect
at the bottom we're looking at
enrichment of ring 1b and Sue's 12 here
at the Hawks the Hawks a low sigh and
again we see very nice enrichment of
both polycomb responsive complex 1 & 2
containing these factors at this low
sigh so with enzymatic chip it's really
important with tissues to to segregate
your tissues into single cell suspension
before you do the digest and this can be
done either using a tissue to segregate
ur like the beckoned Dickinson many
machine or by using a down to moderniser
but once you get that single cell
suspension it's very easy to do the
digest with sonication the sonication
itself will actually disaggregate the
tissue while it's fragmenting the
chromatin however again with sonication
we find that we have to do some
additional optimization to get efficient
and regimen of transcription factors and
cofactors so what we find with tissue is
in sonication that increasing the
cross-linking time hop helps out a lot
when trying to chip for transcription
factors and cofactors so shown on the
left is a gel electrophoresis of DNA
fragments that we've prepared by
sonication for mouse heart mouse brain
and mouse lung and you can see with
increasing cross-linking we do get a
trade off and we get larger chromatin
fragments however if we look at
enrichment of Hawks d-10 and Hawks a1 by
chip qpcr we see that ring 1b and Sue's
12 both which by in this region show
increased enrichment when we cross link
for 30 minutes versus cross-linking for
10 minutes and we see absolutely no
increase in enrichment of this gap th
gene which is an it's not a target of
these complexes and so we find with with
again with sonication if we cross link
just a little bit longer we could
actually increase our enrichment
right so just summarize the first part
of my talk tips for cross-linking and
chromatin fragmentation I'd like to
remind you that I showed you that
histones are resistant to harsh
fragmentation conditions like heat
detergent and the protein denaturation
that's caused transcription factors and
cofactors are sensitive to these harsh
conditions the enzymatic based
fragmentation is mild and it works well
for histones transcription factors and
cofactors sonication does too but you
have to be a you have to do some
optimization and keep some things in
mind and that is you want to use mild
buffers that have low detergent you want
to keep your samples cold you want to
minimize your sonication cycles to
really balance the chromatin fragment
size and the enrichment levels of your
target of interest and finally for
tissue you may want to increase the
cross-linking time to maximize your
transcription cofactor and transcription
factors chip enrichment for more
information about chip you can actually
download our guide for chip and chip
seek @ww cell signal comm slash chip
okay so I want to spend the last part of
my talk talking about antibodies
antibodies are also very important for
the chip assay and when you can you want
to use a chip validated anybody and so a
poll question will come up I'm
interested in hearing what types of
antibodies people are using in their
chip experiments we have rabbit
polyclonal antibodies rabbit monoclonal
antibodies and mouse monoclonal
antibodies and again if you're using
more than one you can check on more than
one box if you haven't done chip yet
just check on the type of antibodies
that you think would work best in the
chip assay and while we do that I'll
move on to my next slide so at CSP our
mission is to deliver the world's
highest quality research products that
accelerate biological understanding and
enable eyes personalized medicine now as
an antibody company this means providing
the best antibodies for all research
applications and so we do extensive
antibody validation across all
applications including chip and when
we're doing this we use
all the tools that we have at our
disposal including positive and negative
cell lines knockout cell lines si RNA
knockdown will use overexpression will
use treatments that induce increases in
protein expression or changes in protein
localization in the cell really anything
that we can do to show that the antibody
is specific is sensitive and also works
reproducibly from one experiment to the
next or one month to the next our
products are produced and rigorously
validated in-house by a CSE scientists
to ensure consistent performance and so
for the chip a say our group validates
our chip antibodies using relevant model
systems and I just show an example here
on this slide here we're looking at
validation of the gluta corticoid
receptor rabbit monoclonal antibody here
we're testing this antibody on a thigh
for nine cells that are either untreated
or treated with dexamethasone now we
know that treatment with dexamethasone
induces nuclear localization of GR and
binding of GR to its target genes in
this experiment we're looking at a
binding to SL c 1982 and mt2 a and both
untreated and treated cells and you see
very nicely we see enrichment only in
the treated cells as expected we also
see no binding to this alpha satellite
repeat element which is our negative
control so here the antibody is showing
exactly what we would expect to see and
that is enrichment of GR targets in
treated cells now when testing an
antibody in your chip assay I I always
advise to titrate the antibody this is
something we do for every antibody that
we test shown here is a titration for
our easy H to rabbit monoclonal antibody
and here what you're looking at is
looking at enrichment of the Hawks a1
and Hawk say to low C as we increase
concentration of the antibody and the
IPS a and you see as we increase the
amount of antibody we do see an increase
in enrichment however that enrichment
levels off and then actually Falls with
increasing amounts of antibody
and so what we find with this antibody
is that two and a half to five
microliters of antibody per IP is ideal
in generating the best signal-to-noise
the best enrichment levels of these
target genes so with an antibody and
chip more is not always better
I know some people still believe that
you need to use five or ten micrograms
of antibody for a chip assay and that's
simply not true sometimes as little as a
half a microgram actually works best and
we find that it's the ratio of the
antibody to the chromatin that's
important so we always titrate the
antibody again when selecting your
antibody for chip it's always good to
look at validation data across different
applications as this often tells you
more about the antibody specificity and
sensitivity so here's an antibody that
we have against BR g1 again it's a
rabbit monoclonal antibody and [ __ ] qPCR
shown in the upper right we're looking
at enrichment of actually two estrogen
receptor target genes estrogen receptor
recruits the vrg one switch sniff
complex to target genes when cells are
treated with estrogen so here we're
looking at mcf-7 cells treated with
estrogen and as expected you see nice
recruitment an enrichment of brg one to
these target genes shown below is chip
seek track again looking at enrichment
of another target gene and and again we
see very nice binding and enrichment of
brg one at the ER binding site in this
in this gene on the left is shown in a
Western blot here we're actually looking
at expression of brg one across a
variety of different cell lines these
are a whole cell lysate and as you can
see this antibody really detects only a
single band in these whole cell life
states now with brg one we know from
mRNA expression data that a five or nine
cells do not express BR g1 as the GAO
pointed out BRM is a paralog of brg one
that's actually highly homologous in
sequence to be our g1 and Burma is
expressed in these a five for nine cells
so we notice since our brg one antibody
does not detect a ban in these cells
that it's not cross reacting with B r1
with
and so we know this antibody is specific
to be RG 1 with gluta corticoid receptor
we already went over the chip qpcr data
or the chip - yeah the chip qpcr data
shown below is the chip seek data and
again looking at a known target gene we
see nice a single peak of enrichment
here over a gr binding site very good
signal-to-noise ratio again looking at
specificity and performance of the
antibody across to other applications if
we look at if' here we're looking at a 5
for 9 cells again that are untreated and
treated and the left we're looking at
untreated and it is expected you see
both nuclear and cytoplasmic
localization once we treat the cells we
see just nuclear localization as
expected since death of dexamethasone
induces nuclear translocation of the of
the protein and finally we have a
Western blot on the left here we're
looking at whole cell lysates from 293
cells that are either untranslated with
an overexpression construct formic
tagged gr and l'ainte in mine 3 or
transfected with a construct
overexpressing
McTigue mineralocorticoid receptor in
lane 4 and again we see this antibody is
very good at detecting endogenous gr
over expressed gr but it doesn't cross
react with their mineral corticoid
receptor protein again showing that it's
specific for gr so want to spend a
little bit of time talking about
trimethylation realizing 27 again here
we're looking at a Western blot of whole
cell lysates
and the antibody detects a single band
that corresponds to histone h3 and i
hope we see the expected nuclear
localization and and chip qPCR we
actually look at enrichment of known
target genes Myo d1 and MIT one these
are two genes that are repressed in
these HeLa cells and are repressed by
polycomb and repressed by this tri
methylates releasing 27 mark and we see
no enrichment of gap th or r PL 30 which
are housekeeping genes that are active
the chip seek data is shown below and we
see the expected kind of broad binding
of
abroad localization of this mark across
MIT one as expected as this is what this
is how polycomb works in on its target
genes so by all accounts and different
applications this antibody looks very
specific
however we know with the histone
modification antibodies that histones
themselves are highly modified on
lysines both by methylation and a set
elation and these antibodies have the
potential to cross react with other
methylated lysines and so for all of our
methyl lysine a set of lysine and methyl
arginine antibodies we do a histone
pepped or a peptide array analysis where
we titrate our antibodies on an array of
peptides that contain all the known
modifications of histone h3 h4 h-2a h-2b
and histone h1 and what we look at is we
look at peptides that have a single mark
and peptides that have dual marks
containing neighboring modifications so
we can look at the effect of neighboring
modifications on binding of the antibody
so for this tribe methylation 27
antibody we see in button column L that
the antibody binds very nicely to a
peptide containing trimethylation lasing
27 how do we see no binding and K&J
which correspond to dimethyl and mono
methyl and no binding in h which
corresponds to try methyl h3 lysine 9
which is highly similar in sequence to
the tri methyl lysine 27 so with this
antibody again we see no binding across
peptides containing a single histone
methylation site and then over here on
the right we look at dual sites we see
that the antibody can bind when upstream
arginine 26 is also die methylated again
showing that this antibody doesn't care
whether the upstream arginine is
methylated so this antibody is highly
specific to K 27 tri methyl so in my
last two slides I just want to talk
about the performance of rabbit
monoclonal antibodies in the chip and
chip seek sa I know a lot of people
believe that polyclonal antibodies work
better for IP based experiments but
that's simply not true some of our best
chip and chip seek antibodies are rabbit
monoclonal antibodies shown here is a
comparison of our tribe methyl lacing 27
antibody against an egg code approved
competitor polyclonal antibody and we're
looking at enrichment of Hawks D and my
OD Louis I at the top and at the bottom
and what we find is with the CST
antibody we see actually better levels
of enrichment and better signals and
noise than we do with the encode
approved competitor polyclonal
antibodies the next slide shows a rabbit
mono that we have against RNA polymerase
largest subunit rpb1 the n-terminal
domain this antibody is used to look at
total RNA polymerase binding across the
genome as the the n-terminal domain does
not contain a lot of the phosphorylation
modifications that the c terminus
contains and so again we're looking at
enrichment of RNA polymerase using our
rpb1
rabbit monoclonal antibody and the
competitor polyclonal antibodies this is
a leading polyclonal antibodies that is
used quite often for chip and chip seek
and we're looking at enrichment of the
znf 740 and the beta-actin genes and
again what we find is the rabbit
monoclonal antibody is superior and
actually gives higher levels of
enrichment and better signal-to-noise
than the polyclonal antibody and as
expected you see high levels of
enrichment over the promoters of these
genes and then you see lower levels
across the body of these genes so
finally I'd like to summarize the last
part of my talk talking about the use of
chip validated antibodies in the assay
so when using an antibody always use a
chip validated antibody if possible but
look at the data across other
applications to look at specificity and
sensitivity use the antibody at
recommended delusions if it's already
provided if not available try using IP
validated antibodies but optimize for
chip by titration and again rabbie
monocline abilities work very well in
chip and chip seek at CSP we over have
over 280 tip validated antibodies and
over 50 of those are
chips seek validated rabbit monoclonal
antibodies for more information you can
visit our website at wwlp.com slash
epigenetics or slash chip and that will
provide a lot of information about our
antibodies our chip kits and epigenetics
in general thank you thank you so much
both of you for your informative
presentation we want to now start that
live Q&A portion of this webinar if you
have any questions you'd like to ask dr.
fry or dr. kadosh please let us know now
just click on that green Q&A button at
the lower left of your presentation
window type your questions into the box
that appear on the screen and click on
the send button well answer as many
questions as we have time for so let's
get started we have an incredible
audience today very captivated first
member has a question directed to you
dr. kadosh first super talk thanks so
much I'm interested in your observation
on the SS 18 SS X containing bath
complex and realization two different
loci then WT did I get that right
question mark sure thanks for the
question
yes you got that right in our 2013 paper
on this we demonstrated that the SS 18s
effects even can retarget bath complexes
to the socks to locus that's the
published observation to date and so to
suggest that this oncogenic fusion can
retarget the complex and in looking at
you and sarcoma related sarcoma with the
EWS y1 fusion we saw that to be true as
well at the GE a repeat enhancer sites
hope that helps
great thank you so much here's another
question from our audience members since
M Emin ace digests naked double-stranded
DNA that locks nucleosomes wood won't I
lose nucleosome-free region of the
genome when preparing chromatin using
yeah Thank You Sussie no that's not the
case we actually and that's why we we
recommend doing a partial digest as you
saw in one of the slides we always do a
partial digest to give us a range of
fragments from 150 to 700 base pairs and
when we do this we have no problem
enriching for transcription factors and
cofactors that bind in traditionally in
nucleosomes free or you know less dense
regions like transcription start sites
and enhancers so with the MAS we still
see actually really good enrichment of
those regions so no you don't you don't
actually lose those regions they think
you dr. fly there's some great questions
coming in from our audience members
here's one I was always told that
polyclonal antibodies work best in IP
and chip assays because they bind
multiple epitopes on any one antigen
well monoclonal antibodies are limited
to binding a single epitope can you
comment on this yeah I mean that's all
that's often one belief in the field is
that you know the polyclonal antibodies
work better because they buying multiple
epitopes but these days most polyclonal
antibodies are made against a peptide of
20 to 22 amino acids and really when
you're limited to that small of a region
for antibody epitope the polyclonal
antibodies n't give you really any
advantage over a monoclonal antibody
that binds to that same region there may
be a couple different epitopes when then
within that region that are bound by the
poly but it has the same propensity
really to be buried or it within the
protein or are exposed and really at
that point it depends on the affinity of
the antibody and really in that case
polyclonal don't have any advantage over
Manos I would just say to add to that to
what Chris said within protein complexes
for sure a good monoclonal that's nicely
designed to what appears to be a surface
exposed epitope is is often far better
than a mixture polyclonal antibodies
where it's a mixture of exposed and
buried epitopes
great thank you so much to further
discuss that here's another question
focusing on the validation of IP
antibodies why high concentrations why
do high concentrations give less
response than optimal concentrations of
antibodies that's that's a good question
and that's actually something that we
don't completely understand I mean we
see we see that with many different
antibodies some antibodies the signal
will increase in plateau and kind of
stay the same other antibodies will
increase and then decrease again even
more drastically than the easy h2
antibody that I showed I mean what we do
find and what we believe you know is
that there's there's a really a the
ratio of antibody to chromatin and that
IP is what's important and so once you
find that that sweet spot that ratio
whether it be 2 micrograms of antibody
10 micrograms of chromatin really that's
what's important and as you scale your
chip experiment as you scale the size of
your IP you want to scale both of those
the same but yeah I mean that's a good
question we really I really don't
understand why adding more antibody
would decrease your enrichment
thank you now I want to thank our
audience for being so involved we have
some wonderful questions coming in
here's our next question
which method of chromatin fragmentation
works best for tissue samples so yeah
that's a that's a very good question
I mean we've looked at five or six
different types of tissues and we find
that both methods work again there are a
couple you know both methods work
equally well except for the with
enzymatic like I said it's really
important to get single cell suspensions
before you do the digest once you do
that the enzymatic works really well
there are some tissues that we found
like muscle tissue for example where
sonication actually seems to work a
little better because sonication does a
better job of of icing the cells and and
getting that the single cell suspension
the the down to moderniser and the meta
machine don't don't work as well but for
most tissues with the exception of some
muscle tissues we think that both work
equally well thank you and dr. fine dr.
kadosh we have time for one more
question from our audience members
here's the last question do I need to
use a water bath sonicator or focused
ultrasonic ATAR could get the best
results for transcription factor and
cofactor chip assays that's another good
question we've actually done some
experiments side by side using the
traditional probe sonicator water bath
sonicator and an ultra sonicator and
what we find is the the probe sonicator
actually is more consistent across
experiments and across cell lines with
the other types of sonic aiders we found
that for four different cell lines you
had to do new optimization and actually
use slightly different buffers or even
sonication times to get the same results
but with the the probe sonicator we were
able to get consistent results from one
experiment to the next and across
multiple cell types and tissues and so
we've actually optimized the the simple
chip
sonication chromatin IP kit using a
probe sonicator yeah so i mean as we
think that works best
I'm just well thank you dr. Kadosh dr.
Frey do you have any closing remarks
you'd like to share with the audience
before we get close today so just a big
thanks to cell signaling technology and
lab roots opportunity thanks so much
yeah thank you so doll very much and
thank you lab roots for supporting our
webinar we really enjoy the opportunity
to to talk with people we want things we
both we want to thank you both and
remind audience members that they can
reach you via email and we also want to
thank cell signal technology for
sponsoring today's webcast as well as
laboratory today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through April 2018 you will receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when the webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and thanks for joining us we hope to see
you again here and our evaporates
virtual conferences bye-bye